let's think about what seven plus six is
and I encourage you to pause this video
and think about it on your own so I'm
assuming you've given a go at it
so let's think about it we could view
this as seven objects plus six more
objects and then think about how many
total objects we had so for example we
could view it as seven say tomatoes so
one tomato two Tomatoes three tomatoes
four Tomatoes five six and seven and
then to that we're going to add six more
objects and let's say they're
blueberries and we care about the total
amount of fruit so one two three four
five and six
six blueberries now how many total
pieces of fruit do I have in all now
well I started with seven so that's
seven and so if I keep counting this is
seven so this is going to be eight nine
ten eleven twelve and thirteen so I now
have a total of thirteen pieces of fruit
thirteen pieces of fruit now what are
other ways that we could have thought
about this well we could have also done
it on a number line so let's draw
ourselves a number line do it in so
let's say we have a number let me do
this in a color that I haven't used yet
actually so let's say I have a number
line so just like that and I could start
the number line at seven I could start
at seven and I'm going to add six more
I'm going to move six more up the number
line so this was one two three four five
six and of course I could keep going
it's going to be eight nine ten eleven
twelve thirteen and of course you could
keep on going but seven plus six you
could visualize this as starting at
seven and then making six jumps up the
number line one
two three four five six either way we
get we get to 13 another way to think
about it is well look we started with
seven we added three to get to ten and
so we have to add another three which
gets us to thirteen and that really goes
to the heart of what the number thirteen
represents the number thirteen has a one
as its left digit this digit is in the
tens place so it literally represents
110 so it's 110 plus three plus three
ones and you see that right over here
that when I added the pieces of fruit
this right over here is one group of ten
so that's one group of ten and so we had
to add three to get to that one group of
ten and then so we kind of filled that
bucket and then we had three more so
we're left when you add seven plus six
you fill one whole group of ten and then
you have three ones left over so this is
the three ones right over here so
another way to think about it is seven
plus six is the same thing as 10 plus
three which of course is 13 so this is
the same thing 110 is ten plus three
plus three ones thirteen either way you
look at it